Over 250 people are dead and thousands of
military members have been arrested after
an attempted coup against Turkish President
Recep Tayyip Erdoğan. Though he was on vacation
at the time, Erdoğan reached the media through
Facetime and urged his supporters into the
streets of Ankara and Istanbul. Now the increasingly
authoritarian president is likely to use the
botched coup as pretext to continue consolidating
power. We don’t yet know who was behind
the plot, but a faction within the military
issued a statement saying they sought “to
reinstate constitutional order, human rights
and freedom.” They called themselves the
Peace at Home council. That’s reference
to Mustafa Kemal Attaturk, the military officer
who established Turkey’s secular state from
the ashes of the old Ottoman Empire in 1923.
Since Turkey’s founding, the military has
seen itself as defenders of the secular and
democratic principles of Kemalism. So whenever
the nation’s political order was challenged,
the military would intervene. But the latest
attempt didn’t appear to have the full support
of military leaders, which is likely one reason
it failed. Erdogan is blaming the latest coup
attempt on Gülenists, the followers of exiled
Sunni cleric Fetullah Gulen, who now lives
in Pennsylvania. Once an ally to Erdoğan,
Gülen’s media outlets have accused the president
of corruption. And in response, Erdoğan seized
Gulen’s media assets and labeled his sizeable
political party a terrorist movement. Now,
Erdoğan is calling for the US to arrest and
extradite Gulen, who in turn, alleges that
Erdoğan himself staged the whole thing. There
may not be an appetite for military coups
among Turks today, but Erdoğan is increasingly
unpopular. As prime minister for 11 years
before being elected president in 2014, he
has pushed for constitutional changes that
would grant him more power, cracked down on
domestic protests, and prosecuted dissenting
academics and journalists. This guy was even
put on trial for photoshopping Erdoğan next
to Gollum from Lord of the Rings. And the
fact that he built himself a thousand-room
palace didn’t calm concerns that he’s
got plans for long-term rule. A publicly religious
man, Erdoğan raised eyebrows among Turkey’s
staunch secularists with school reforms that
expand Islamic education. And he’s been
criticized for allowing Turkey’s southern
border with Syria to remain porous. This has
made Turkey an entry point for ISIS fighters.
The European Union may have some leverage
to encourage reform, since Turkey has long
sought to join the union. But Turkey’s political
stability is vital.
Europe depends on Erdoğan to help manage the
ongoing Syrian refugee crisis. and the US
uses airbases there to stage bombing raids
against ISIS in Syria. Right now Turkey’s
first order of business will be to re-establish
political order. And early indications from
Erdoğan and his allies suggest his methods
will not be democratic in nature.